[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute gibt es eine torte und zwar habe
ich mir was hübsches ausgedacht ich
hoffe es funktioniert auch so wie ich
mir das ausgedacht haben nämlich ein
süßes körbchen als torte und
ich mache jetzt eine etwas kleine torte
weil ich finde dass die größe die ich
gleich zubereiten würde ausreichen wird
falls sie aber eine größere torte machen
wollt weil er zum beispiel eine größere
familie habt dann könnt ihr gerne in
meiner app vorbeischauen und euch da die
zutaten dann auch gerne immer um rechnen
soviel dazu ich fange jetzt erst mal an
mit dem mantel rührteig normalerweise
ist es mein mangel rührteig aber ich
habe heute ein bisschen ungewiss denn
das öl ist er kratzt ein bisschen knapp
deswegen gibt es keinen sonnenblumenöl
sondern einfach sahne statt butter milch
und sonnenblumenöl und den teig
gestalten wird einfach ein bisschen
anders für den teig verwende ich für
eine prise salz 200 gramm zucker etwas
vanille extrakt 200 gramm sahne
225 gramm mehl backpulver oder ihr
verwendet das bak mehr da ist schon
backpulver enthalten und 50 gramm
gemahlene mandeln das war es jetzt
erstmal den ofen habe ich schon
vorgeheizt auf 170 grad ober unterhitze
und jetzt könnt ihr die ehe mit dem
zucker salz und vanille extrakt erstmal
cremig verrühren
[Musik]
habt ihr schon mal meine 2 back kringe
auf 18 cm durchmesser eingestellt und in
backpapier eingeschlagen weil der teig
dann doch relativ flüssig ist jetzt gebe
ich hier die sahne dazu
[Musik]
die wert kurz eingerührt
und dann könnt ihr bereits mehl mit
backpulver mischen bei mir ist es jetzt
schon vermischt und das packt man muss
man auch nicht sieben ein anderes mail
dürfte jetzt gerne 7 damit nicht klumpt
und könnte jetzt mehl backpulver und die
mandeln zum teig geben
[Musik]
und natürlich den teig ist hier ein
schön halbieren und dann direkt im ofen
backen für etwa 30 minuten
[Musik]
und solange kümmere ich mich jetzt schon
mal um die creme
für die füllung nämlich 200 gramm bernd
entweder nimmt die frisch oder
tiefgefroren eine dose pfirsiche davon
den saft auffangen 250 kva etwas mann
hinter extrakt 400 gramm sahne und
seiner partnerstadt schlagen ihr seht
ihr dass ich keinen puderzucker in der
creme habe ihr könnt natürlich auch
gerne puderzucker nehmen ungefähr 80
gramm oder verwendet einfach hier den
diese flüssigkeit aus der dose denn dann
spart ihr euch eigentlich den zucker
könnte das nehmen müsst nicht
wegschütten und könnte die himbeeren mit
der flüssigkeit schön einkochen es
dauert jetzt dann natürlich ein bisschen
länger mit dem einkochen weil natürlich
jetzt extrem viel wasser drin ist aber
wie gesagt das spart euch einfach die
weitere zutaten nämlich sind butter
zucker und habe eben nichts verschwendet
jetzt einfach so lange einkochen lassen
bis die flüssigkeit fast verkauft ist
[Musik]
das einkochen dauert jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen länger weil ich eben die
flüssigkeit benutzt habt falls sie zeit
sparen wollte da nimmt am besten den
puderzucker da ist nämlich keine
flüssigkeit drin aber ihr könnt das
ganze auch gern mit stärker einfach an
dicken mir so eine art pudding und dann
schön einkochen und dann wird es auch
fest und sobald der pudding jetzt dick
ist wenn ich ihn um füllen damit er
einfach schnell abkühlt und ich gleich
weiter
[Musik]
das leben bleibt schön abgekühlt und ich
hatte auch solange die sahne und quark
mit meinem kühlschrank also da immer
darauf achten die zutaten nicht bei
raumtemperatur stehen lassen ansonsten
medisana nämlich viel zu warm
und dann kann ich jetzt hier das team
bei pury mit dem quark schon mal
verrühren dass sich jetzt auch schon
vorbereitet habe ich habe auch schon den
40 stücke fein gehackt beziehungsweise
einfach gewürfelt
[Musik]
internets ihr schon mal die sahne
zugießen und mit seiner fahrt steif
schlagen
[Musik]
ich nehme ich erst mal die tortenböden
löste raus
[Musik]
und dann mit einer torte säge oder mit
einem torten messer einfach aber
halbieren
das sind schon mal durch
[Musik]
dann nehme ich jetzt den ersten
tortenboden wie gesagt ihr schreitet die
tortenböden entweder zwei oder einmal
durch und habe somit vier oder sechs
einzelne böden und dann wird das ganze
schön gefüllt
und ich gucke immer also ich mit sechs
bilden also muss ich die creme
wenn ich oben keine creme haben wir auf
5 auf teilhabe ich will oben drauf ohne
creme also 66 teile kriege
und jetzt hier ein bisschen was rein
streichen
und am besten ist es tatsächlich erfüllt
die torte direkt in den ring ich setze
meinen auch gleich drumherum aber damit
jetzt noch kurz seht was ich hier mache
lasse ich ihn kurz weg denn dann bekommt
ihr es auch hin dass die torte schön
gerade wird also für ungeübte ist schon
immer besser im tortenring trocken zu
füllen
ich muss sagen ich habe die creme grad
schon probiert die ist schon sehr lecker
sehr fruchtig und pfirsich himbeer passt
sowieso perfekt zusammen für sich selber
nennt man das dann auch tatsächlich
für sich mehr erwartet
dann kommt ihr der nächste boden drauf
und die torte rutschen gefüllt und immer
darauf achten schön gerade streicher
ansonsten hat dir irgendwann so eine
kugel torte ich hab das auch so der
größte fehler den man macht dass man die
creme neben google mäßig auf streicht
außer man will eine kuppel torte aber
wenn sie schon gerade werden sollte muss
die cremig
[Musik]
immer schön mit einem geraden boden
abschließen
und dann kommt da jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen creme drauf aber keine pässe
mehr
ich habe nicht damit gerechnet dass die
doch so hoch wird
jetzt kurz und großen und hohen trocken-
ringt um so wird jetzt auch gehen aber
ich denke meine torten halt immer gerne
ab
wir wollten da übrigens ihre torten rand
folie drumherum setzen dann ist später
das haus neben einfacher aber mit so
einem tortenring messer geht's halt auch
totenrede drauf und ab weniger schrank
für etwa zwei stunden das reicht schon
ihr seht ihr auch jetzt schon sonderbar
tisch schön fest die creme ist ab jetzt
kann sich alles mal setzen und ich kann
so lange kann so gar nicht fassen und
ich kann so lange die schotten deko
vorbereiten
ich versuche jetzt mal noch ein ja so
ein henkel zu flechten dafür nämlich
jetzt trat und weil ich nicht sind ganz
stabilen drahthaar zwiebel ich zwei
drähte umeinander und
werde dann aus schokoladen fondant in
weiß und dunkel da was drum rum flechten
hoffe ich
das wird schon funktionieren
ich glaube ich komm nicht klar
plan b plan b besteht aus zwei strängen
kaum scheitern so
cacau
hat das erste mal nicht funktioniert
wir hatten mittagessen und heute morgen
dachte ich die fakten rohstoff und dann
nur das zu nehmen was
wäre fast verzweifelt ich sag's euch
setzen wir mal die torte um
hey
und dann nimmst du noch mal ein bisschen
creme von oben streckt sie auch an den
rand und könnte jetzt den rand entweder
mit
war für welchen dekorieren oder
mit mikadostäbchen und leider haben wir
zu wenige oder fluren und deswegen dem
ricardo ja und dann binden schleife drum
rum und dann wird es echt ne schöne
torte
das gefällt mir super
so kommen jetzt die ganze mikado es um
die torte herum oder die waffe geld und
ihr könnt euch das auch ein bisschen
ausmessen die tat 18 zentimeter im
durchmesser und dann können wir den
umfang berechnen das sind ungefähr 55 cm
und dann legt ihr euch die süßigkeiten
nebeneinander ein päckchen könnte das
ausmisten sage ich es meinem ja und dann
wusste ich genau ok 3,5 päckchen brauche
ich oder er kauft einfach ging
[Musik]
also solle dick kann echt jeder das
kriegt jeder hin zu erfüllen karlsruhe
[Musik]
ich verrate euch jetzt ein geheimnis
aber es bleibt unter uns okay
die weißen waren aus
was ist die rückseite
sieht man doch gar nicht jede torte hat
der rückseite
okay da kommt jetzt ein geschenk machen
wir da ganz lustig gerne
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier aus der oster
abteilung einfach kleine schoko eier
genommen
und da mir hier die farbe jetzt nicht so
gut gefallen hat fertig die jetzt noch
ein da könnt ihr immer ganz gerne
lebensmittel farbpulver nehmen gibt es
ganze in eine schüssel schüttelt die
ordentlich darin und dann haben sie eine
richtig schöne farbliche ummantelung
da kommen jetzt die eier rhein
besteht
blümchen machen wir noch drauf
[Musik]
hätte ich
jetzt kann die tat probiert werden von
meinen zwei osterhäschen tolga untertan
[Applaus]
keine osterhasen ohren warum haben wir
so was nicht hier wenn doch alles in
unserer verkleidungs kisten
müssen wir ändern wie fällt ihr das
osterfest
hat bei uns gibt es halt keine stand
aber die kinder halt in der schule und
im kindergarten
und natürlich male mir auch an aber das
ist ja farbe hat ja eigentlich nichts
mit ostern zu tun ja schon eher so ein
frühjahrs braun geholt evangelischer
glaube ich sind die auferstehen jesu
christi
großer großer
feiertag
genau
und darauf die auf die ostereier die man
immer geschenkt kriegt hat von nachbarn
immer von den nachbarn
also der antritt ist schon bisl
schwierig muss man sagen
es geht ihm lieb war
genau das
ist aber
[Musik]
schön
[Gelächter]
damit dieser kürze
hab doch wem spaß
so probierte mal
aber sieht wunderschön und
ich probiere wenigsten krieg frisch
der gurken
richtig lecker die creme die schmeckt
echt wie so ein joghurt ja
gibt 40 passen gut dazu
zudem im
bund net so süß findet auch
verwechslung ostergeschenk
unser vater wir
unbedingt
da pokémon und
sagt uns wie es schmeckt
gut möglich
ohne spaß ok dann glaube ich dir also
falls er die torte nachbacken wollt dann
tut das gerne ich finde sie echt hübsch
und jutta was wird sagen schon einfache
eigentlich von der zu bereichern doch
wirklich wenn man also dass mit dem tod
ringt drum rum und dann die torte so
füllt das kriegt wirklich
gut wenn das theater sagt dann ist das
also freie hand hätten probleme mit dem
tod ringen darum geht gern ja also wie
gesagt wenn ihr torten für den
tortenring das recht für anfänger immer
ganz gut und diese diese dekoration
drumherum finde ich sehr schön einfach
hat ja einfach einfach sagt sollten also
viel spaß beim nachhaken das rezept
findet sie aussah ließ - blog de oder in
meiner app wir wünschen euch jedenfalls
viel spaß dabei die bestellung ist
direkt ein paar osterhasen teilchen und
fürs nächste jahr und dann sehen wir uns
nächste woche wieder
[Musik]